yes my streaming minutes from chester
and for commitment are
going to be deducted
9 30. i'll start the timer i thought
that you're supposed to castle first did
maximix ups did his prep again or is he
prepped to play this because i i know
the line with short castle and then
depending on the knight 92 knight f3 you
can do different things i've looked as
forever in the old days you went castle
92 c5 and 92 you can go b5 that's not
some that depends with your stuff but
knife three you can go c5 yeah which is
very very trendy but
but maximum goes for just b5 in either
case i think that's also probably
possible they're following some game
do both nippon
where i think they're following the game
every carlson mvl from earlier today
that one too but now knight c6 this is
the improvement he now follows nepalese
he played bishop g4 in the classical
which is oh is that yeah
but but
how is did he get better after this was
mungus blunderson move or what happened
there
um
yeah it was more
step by step i think well
four rook c8 okay this is the classical
here h3 the computer like it's a bishop
e3 and what is better i'll have to h3
black is somehow in time
and then he didn't want to pull the
brakes to earlier
keep it complicated like at worst
but now
something different happened we won
knight c6
onto e5 yeah so this is different from
the game ugly what black is doing now
bishop five really
rock b8 first of all looks a bit passive
you should be efficient
okay
jesus christ
okay so you take that one presumably
he did yeah must be terrible right
what's his idea
i mean is his idea
i mean i don't understand
no apparently
he just wants to keep the pawn alive
compy running here says dc5 is the best
move which looks counter-intuitive as
well but then this black is okay you
know
zero seventy or nine seventy after queen
d195 is not okay
it looks very very little
knight d4 is quite heavy
yeah but intuitively it feels like it's
drawing something six or eight
like i wouldn't think dc is the thing
but of course you were really happy to
keep the bishop on your sound queen d3
looks normal no attacking yes i i'm
curious if magnus in uh
in a rapid game is able to
play dc
dc is the kind of move that is very hard
for
people like me but he can of course pull
it off sometimes
um the computer's second choice is
actually to develop the bishop to a3 but
i agree you know
now that the king has been opened up i
mean i would be looking just one
direction yeah you think that something
there yeah happens and
bishop a3 is also a neat tactic because
after before you've got queen a4 yeah e3
of course yeah this is the move we all
would make
yeah yeah
no
queen d7 zeros
oh yeah because e6 is not good yeah
because of some bishop g56 i guess we
take
bishop g595 another 95 minutes i'll just
take on b5
because i'm not in time so cd first and
if cd first cd first and then e6
that's possible
what's after cd
apparently queen f5
oh yeah that's not surprising so 95 just
checkmate that's quite obvious yeah you
just missed that okay
well 27 okay
we'll we'll have to do it
you have to do it not to make it not
that difficult to move also
no
but i have to say the computer does say
that after paunte's porn he is surviving
after queen takes you f5 but it looks
ugly
yeah it just looks like you're not
trying to be honest like i don't see the
line that what is the line so the line
is basically that uh once e64 not even
25
okay but i mean okay take cd looks
completely lost this position
is just
lost yeah
yeah like this surviving is okay also
our market done with three minutes less
good luck yep and uh talking about the
time control uh maxim has uh just over
four and a half minutes so lots of time
whilst magnus is still nurturing his
time advantage and he has over seven and
a half minutes the three minutes always
good to watch out for the three minutes
yeah like so now again the three-minute
advantage is restored that's a good news
for white as long as you keep that three
minutes that means that things are going
very well time-wise
yeah i think you will have to find 27 by
elimination it's just strange it takes
him that long but he will make it
because there's another move there he
comes of course
you just it's just basic calculation for
maxim you rule out all the other moves
and then you just find this one and uh
now well magnus has to find the point
attack
magnus being in a must-win situation i
like his chances yeah i've seen the
worst positions for white and rugged on
being one rook d8
before
f4 23 then shove bishop to h6 and try to
give you checks gain more time
enough like him
that's how old most games are here and
no just by flagging i think
people are just collapsing so
it's it's nice uh format i think it's
really good you've got the classical
chess where people are
uh you know looking like like
old-fashioned come up with interesting
ideas in the opening play interesting
games and then for action you just end
all the games for flagging i think
that's quite nice yeah one takes pawn oh
you know
we think that uh there's something to be
said for just having a tournament of
armageddons yeah for sure for sure yeah
we double the prices double the prices
yeah
because the double they know for people
they
so much stress
no but you don't have to play the
classical just five armageddons per day
right
yeah that's that's why i
have to say
how to say times five like i know
quadruple and then quintuple can take
content
yeah this is going to be a nice
tournament juicy press one 500 a day
by the end of the day
it's a good holiday yeah and 300k first
price yep and just to remind everyone of
the time control
so there is no increment until the
players reach
move 40. no this would be five sorry one
five five can be five ninety five i
think um
i didn't realize that uh you're still
going on about the time control because
it's quite complicated so it takes time
to
yeah explain your time control
yeah before as well but also take 95.
yeah yeah we should have 6 i like that i
like that yep i like that too and uh
followed by h4 h5 queen g5 h6 for only
h6
old-fashioned
yeah it's h6 spots
okay queen f4 on the board i mean maybe
there's ideas of actually just trying to
bulldoze the black pawn structure by
just going g4 h4 i'm a big fan of h4 i
think the first try would be to go some
just direct mate and then if that
doesn't work we'll switch to the the
pawn storm normally you try to made by
pieces on knight g6 it just needs to
attack long enough to get into the
flagging no like yeah objectively
black's fine
so a yeah there's room g8
now you can take in d5
oh no
d5
so okay one takes pawn is that also
strong or it's just pretty
minus zero fifty so it's not just pretty
simple
actually black can just simply capture
the pawn and maximum has done that oh
there's a tush soup bishop g7 f4 sushi
oh
he missed that that's why he should have
taken on your sound first oh this is so
dirty so unfair oh okay so unfair
didn't happen yet but but it's not going
to happen that's why it's queen h3 is
going to go forward but is this so bad
for yeah it's very bad
no any chances
to play whatever h3
is three some more things in h3
i mean can he go h4 yeah
nice yeah but then queen g4 and it's
like
nice you're attacking the wrong thing
instead
yeah
stylish d4 c4
then take the e6 somewhere ah there's
some
loose rock
yeah magnus playing stylish chess that's
how you should play dance but isn't it
yeah e6 not a problem okay e6 on the
problem here you six f4 or something or
whatever right before on the boardwork
c4 but i mean
that's not the problem maximum f4 queen
takes just six i've changed it's not
working six plates wow it just takes
wait what
uh exchange like it's not nice it's
after bishop takes bishop we've got f4
again again and uh
isn't it great for black this is great
for black
and even better than that zero zero zero
so it's suppose it's still possible to
soften up the pawns somehow
maybe blacking is slightly weak but it's
really a long-term thing because all the
pieces are around at bishop and the
knight yeah i think that to be honest i
would think that black is just trolling
and maximus
seems very happy magnus is thinking that
he's messing it up
and uh okay let's always remind
ourselves of the clock situation because
maxim just has two minutes remaining was
magnus okay he has five he has a
three-minute lead following the geary
rule yeah except except at some point
maxim will have like 30 seconds magnus
30 and he will resign the game and i
feel like yep okay the rook moves to one
attacking g6 is nicely nicely the the
square yeah do you want to go to
controls everything yeah he's about okay
f7 pawn is nice yeah it's important when
your seven is good yeah and uh will
black start uh rolling down the pawns
yes chucky likes to show you know
just
the point is
yeah it's hopeless it's hopeless
yeah but okay
and what's it like playing with this one
second increment is it just
i mean it's a little you flag a little
bit easier than the 10 second increment
but you still flag it's basically the
same thing
one second is the is you know like when
you're kind of drowning completely and
you give this very thin
very very thin
not even wooden stick this chopstick you
give you're like grab it oh you're still
drowned okay well you gave you gave you
we gave you a stick you know but i don't
know why you didn't hold on to it it was
a stick yeah but it's a very thin one
yeah but it was a stick so you know yeah
talking about stick i mean that we saw
the players repeat moves a few times and
now g3 and h4 presumably is going to
come yeah for a like also oh he went f4
oh
i like that move why not stopping h4
just to be sure some fgfg softens up the
the king side okay getting rid of the
double pawns as well quite
nice move 33 quincy
actually jokes aside um
white did control the pawns a little
here yeah like they are somewhat blocked
it's not it doesn't look hopeless to me
anymore i see i see how he could r1 how
he could somehow
yeah in fact the best move is actually
play pawn takes knight anything else
probably to draw that so yeah okay queen
e3
correct knight comes into d3 what a game
by maxine by the way yeah from a human
viewpoint just great play
fantastic okay rick moves to b1 and uh
okay now he's under a minute you're
happy with end games when this uh c
pawns running
bishop on the six controls everything
dominates they have three nights so
yeah complete control for rupees seven
last chance go for the end game
on the good okay because se will be very
nice it will the pawn will control the
deep one now you only have one password
to deal with yeah it's still business
chances chances see three roxy seven
that's not okay
you can play bishop b
b2
yeah but i will stop you on c2 probably
anything yeah but then i go around
on d4
yeah but the the a2 pawn is up for grabs
is there no knight e1 trick after bishop
b2 yes okay
yeah consider that a three knight c2
yeah surprise white is still not winning
anywhere you're like
if you take and take on a2 and
you're stuck now you just will move the
king
up yeah the boring probably hold up a
three a two and maybe white holes but
nothing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah 91
check it will always be there
knight e1 91
just take the porn
today is just in a great form
he got in the zone i guess in the unrest
day getting ready to play magnus with
his prep
and now completely completely on fire
bishop takes porn but okay this is bad
news for magnus and he's now lost like
three armageddons this could be the
fourth
fourth in a row
okay king defends the night
uh so
fourth in a row what if you lose this
one it's four in the world he lost he
lost all the arguments pretty much
this is absolutely insane he lost to
wesley to vishy it's an insane piece of
stat wow to aryan to aryan and now this
one
anyone losing all our magazines is weird
but like the best player okay
and uh very very wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
there's uh are you sure
seconds wait time
okay so he's actually played rugby one
doesn't look happy about it
yeah because that's crazy touch piece
gonna move it okay rugby one again there
are these intermediate tricks
and too many pawns probably the king can
join one of them it's king of six it's
not like you ever win yeah king of six
players it's really precise q3 you just
give me fire for what
h3 can still run
oh oh oh oh the bar says no the bar says
no
i know what happened
the night before the computer is not a
fan of now it says it's winning
oh my god position
oh he could have gotten given a check
and taken the pawn he left the scene oh
that's why they both they both missed
that that's why they both went for it
okay but is it what is going on it still
looks kind of half winning
jumped again apparently
how is this winning look at his clock
though look he has two seconds yeah he
has no time at all
but okay he will go forward with the
king and magnus has to find him no but
it's 20 for what king d3 kg4 um king 2
king g3
i guess check check and king of two
rouge one check and he have two yeah oh
yes
oh yes yeah yeah he will find that he'll
find it oh oh here's one minute 45
seconds that extra three minutes now to
calculate yeah it's also such an easy
line you bring the king closer and then
you give the roku one check your card of
the kingdom it's very easy you'll find
it eventually
so
what happened here earlier because it
said c2 king c3 it said it's a draw here
it's a good game
h3 is still drawing
and that's only moving quite insane by
the way
wow i've never seen
more
lucky